so I think I the first time we we sat
down I think I asked you this so this
seems like the right segue for it so for
everything that we've talked about here
and and the addiction to outrage and all
that there's gonna be a certain amount
of people that are watching this and
going wait a minute glenn beck was one
of the people that was peddling this
stuff mm-hmm
I as well I I think I know you pretty
well right now and I feel like you are
honest in your beliefs and you've you've
had some maiya culpas about some of the
things you've said even just you got
into something on twitter with my friend
Majnu Oz and you fully he sent you a
clip of something that you did about him
a couple of years back and you fully you
apologized immediately you said I'd love
to talk to you and learn more and all of
those things I just asked him today what
he said was he coming in yeah and I know
and I love you guys in an email right so
is there anything you can add to that
about just sort of how you've changed
like do you remember a moment was there
something about that because maybe there
are people that are going down that road
right now that still want more the
outrage and still or still or you know
as they call it [ __ ] posting on Twitter
and the rest of it if you were trying to
get somebody to turn back no cuz there
were really personal experiences I went
from the you know that that global poll
that comes out around Christmas time you
know most admired man of the world yeah
I was tied with the Pope
just behind Nelson Mandela okay that's
insane that's insane twelve months later
I'm no longer on that list
yeah I'm hated yeah I was saying the
same things on CNN but I was saying on
Fox hey
so that was confusing and it was you
know you can't be hated by half of the
country I mean unless you're just a you
know maniacal you know
egomaniac that is just beyond any kind
of redemption you cannot be hated by
half of the country you know a false
hero for the other half of the country
and not go I'm not that
I don't think I'm that so Who am I what
part of it most people will go well they
spent millions of dollars to destroy my
reputation to take things out of context
and they did but I also did things
because my philosophy at the time was if
I can get enough eyeballs I can get
people to watch which puts me in
lederhosen you know singing a device I
can get people to watch yeah
then I present them with facts and my
opinion of where it's going forget about
everything else they'll hang on to the
facts and someone in the press will go I
hate that so I'm gonna prove him wrong
they never did mm-hmm
they never would look at the facts so
this is always where they just want to
belittle you and change the street
violence and and I and I helped them
okay I added to that so I'm not saying
it's somebody else I am taking my my
responsibility but the biggest thing is
now on the other side I can look and say
wait all of you in the press you said I
was the worst let me go get the
transcripts see what I just said that's
what you said to the 10th power right
here it's they won't work it's wrong and
it won't work but nobody wants to do
that nobody wants to look they everyone
wants to point to the other person
nobody's willing to go said me but you
think that 70% that you mentioned before
maybe is starting to do that a little
bit I mean again I'm trying if I'm
trying to find how to get out of this
okay and and I think that 70% where I'm
meeting that I know it's a select group
because they're coming they're coming to
see me and yours and take 70% yeah take
17 yeah 10 committed 10 percent
committed changes the world 17 is your
tipping point so it doesn't take all of
us Revolution was fought by about 20% of
America okay those were the ones who
said I believe in this
okay we have to we have to understand it
a lot of the book is about
post-modernism and how that works and
what its goals are what does postmodern
even mean what is what's the modern
world it's not about a machine it's
about the scientific process it's about
exploration and empirical data and
testing a and B and living with the
results that's what the modern world is
so when you realize so you would say
postmodern really is anti modern an
asset because it'sit's going against the
ways that we've been able to measure
anything the way we've been able to look
at it only you can when you don't
understand post-modernism and you read
the headline which I did math is racist
you either go these people are out of
there in minds and I can't take it
anymore or you can say how how did they
get there when you ask that question you
start to go and peel the layers down and
you see the core of this idea good or
bad that what came out of the modern era
the Enlightenment was this and they say
this is bad they say this is bad that
really is it yeah and anything that
holds this up must be destroyed
if that's math if that's you doesn't
matter if you understand that it's all
about deconstruction and deconstruction
is all about chaos you must not do
anything to hasten the chaos it you have
to restrain yourself the best way to
fight this isn't about Gandhi oh I want
to be just like Jesus no I want to win
mm-hmm and the best way to win is to
restrain yourself from adding any of the
chaos be clear be stuff spoken be the
person that everybody in the room when
everybody is arguing they kind of look
around the room and there's maybe three
people over there that are just laughing
and having fun and just because you will
be the
that will control the room in the end
everybody else will kill themselves but
the the majority of people will go oh I
hate this and they'll make their way
over to you that's what we have to do we
have to stop fighting on the stupid
stuff the stupid stuff gay wedding cakes
good god man yeah feeling homosexuals
right now today in parts of the country
what do you say we start there what do
you say we talk about something that
really makes a difference really makes a
difference
we'll get to the gay wedding cakes yeah
let's be good people first yeah it's so
interesting how people just don't want
to do the intellectual work and now it's
like we have these we have these phones
we have endless distractions to the
point that perhaps 20 years ago you
might have a moment standing on a corner
waiting for a friend to go to dinner
where you'd have to think but we can
distract ourselves to the point where we
actually never have to think anymore
when was the last time you just stood
somewhere I mean I know you're aware of
all of this stuff but where was let's
have you Glenn Beck just stood somewhere
on the corner waiting for your wife to
meet you and you weren't looking at your
phone or you weren't you know I tried to
do what you did but I can't do it for
months
I'm too many employees that I only have
like five I I I tried to do it once a
week don't make it every time but just
I'm not going to be online do not pick
up your device go out on a date with
your wife and do not carry a device
doesn't have it with you that's
important and it's important Dave
because I learned something with my
alcoholism I was struggling with so many
things when I was younger that I didn't
want to think about I didn't want to
think about I didn't want to think about
the things that I had done in my life
the things that I was oh poor me about I
just don't want to think about it and I
would turn on the radio and I
and up loud and I'd be driving my car
and I never really consciously connected
the two it got to the point where is so
bad that if I didn't have something to
distract I would literally be by myself
and I go just to block out my thoughts
okay that's a problem and I realized
when I was finally no longer I was sober
and not and not just not drinking was
the time that I was driving someplace
and I must've been driving for about an
hour and I hadn't turned anything on and
I realized at one point I'm just driving
and I kind of come to you know kind of
come to thinking you know about what's
in the car what's happening and I'm like
oh wonder it's on the rate oh my gosh
I've been alone with myself and my
thoughts for an hour that's a sign of
mental health yeah we're sick we're sick
so in the in the book in the in the
foreword you very graciously and I'm
humbled that you did it you included me
and a list of names of people that you
that you put in there and you know Ben
had this and I wrote I even wrote to Ben
I wrote an inscription on this page yeah
like two days later he calls me oh my
gosh we were with each other for two
days yeah and he was like hey thanks
very much and then like at midnight one
night I get this text he's a busy guy I
know to those who are willing to step
out in front of the crowd to question
reason and have dangerous conversations
men with whom I'm a strongly would
disagree with at times but we'll all I
will always consider refound errs of
reason and contemporary heroes Ben
Shapiro Dave Rubin Jordan Peterson brett
weinstein sam harris Jonathan Sacks Penn
Jillette Joe Rogan so I thought I don't
want to make this about me so the one
that I thought was most interesting
there actually was sam Harris because I
suspect you guys probably if he
disagrees with Jordan Peterson on
everything pretty much everything policy
existentialism mean
life the whole damn thing you guys
probably disagree on everything plus one
I don't know if we went to know and I
thought well this is what it's all about
this is what it's all about so but would
you have ever I mean 20 years ago if you
were writing a book you wouldn't you we
still would've done that when I often
joked that my library is a library of a
serial killer because I was too broke to
actually go get a formal education so I
would go to Barnes & Noble or the
library and it go who hates each other
this opinion who hates this opinion that
person and I would read them both and I
would look at them and say is there
anything where they intersect because
that I know is true if both these people
are from opposite ends of the spectrum
and they both say this is true I know
that one line in both books is true okay
so start small and build the basis of
truth and what motivated me was a line
from Thomas Jefferson that he wrote to
his nephew Peter Carr Peters parents had
both died when his dad was ill he said
can you please educate my son when he
comes of age so Thomas writes this
unbelievable letter you know in
mathematics you have to do this some
literature you have to do this the last
thing is religion I love it it's changed
my life when it comes to religion above
all things fix reason firmly in her seat
and question with boldness even the very
existence of God for if there be a god
he must surely rather honest questioning
over blindfolded fear we break down on
the word honest hmm honest questioning
you and I like each other and get along
because you haven't asked me a set up
question and I've never asked you a set
up question it's an honest question hang
on just a second yeah but but that right
but that that isn't as good yeah that
keeps you young that keeps you alive
the minute you stir I knew my father was
gonna die my father was the kind of guy
who always had a book in his back pocket
okay self educated man and he's always
exploring and questioning and he was so
granola fruitloop be one with the
universe kind of guy huh and I called
him up we were best friends for a long
time and I'd call him sometimes two
three times a day and we just talked
about books were reading and things and
did you hear this opinion what do you
think of this we talked about the future
the past all of it and I said dad I just
read this fantastic book you have to
read this I'm gonna send it to you and
he said mm-hmm that's okay and I said
what and he said I'm tired I'm tired I
think I've learned enough huh three
years later he was he was gone when you
when you are not we're built to explore
and when you're not exploring let's left
what would you be doing if you weren't
doing this I told my wife when she
married me is one reason I've lucked out
so much my wife hates Fame
she hates wealth she hates red carpet
she hates all of it because she married
me and her family was like you know
marry him he is a loser
he's not going to a match he's not going
to amount to anything when she married
me because I'm the first out of every
generation that we can find going back
I'm the first male that has not become a
baker and so I would probably probably
be a chef in some place or I'm not good
at baking it but I was just gonna say
would you bake me a cake that's the no
I'm not good at baking I'm good my
father said baking Sun is about formulas
cooking is yeah winging it yeah and I'm
not
formulas yeah impatient you're
definitely a winging it kind of guy so
generally speaking do you feel it's
funny the first half of what we've done
here was sort of fire and brimstone sort
of or laying out you know this is this
thing could really go off the rails I
think the last 20 minutes or so it's
been a little more hopeful I'm an
optimistic catastrophist
you do not want me you do not want to be
anywhere near me on the Titanic until we
get to the iceberg
as we're going to the iceberg I'm saying
are you kidding me have you counted the
lifeboat there's not enough light folks
we're headed into cold area if there is
if these people they're gonna be
irresponsible they're not gonna pay
attention to the ice but they're
arrogant they're gonna hit the iceberg
and you're all gonna die okay as soon as
we hit that iceberg I'm there we're
gonna make it we're gonna make it
because I believe that when people are
awake they will awaken to who they truly
are and I think Americans are different
we have this spirit in us of exploration
we're the people who cross the oceans
we're the people that cross the Rockies
I have to tell you if I were alive
during the you know the time when we
were exploring I don't even think I
would have made it past the Missouri but
definitely I would have gotten to Denver
in a way okay guys I am NOT going
anywhere I'm crossing this okay I always
think every time I'm on the what is it
the five that goes by the the Getty
Museum with which is that the 405 yeah
yeah
the 405 we bumped to LA yeah I see the
Getty Museum up there and I think if I
were a pioneer and I made it this far I
would have built my house in this valley
and people would have been on the top of
the hill going you should see what saw
like I am done but generally people are
explorers and they're good and they're
they're hearty and they want to live I
think they do want to live and they want
to live in peace and her
I think that about the Palestinians and
the Israelis when if you could and I've
done it I've done it when you don't have
a camera in somebody's face and nobody
knows you're talking you sit down in a
house of a Palestinian and most likely
average person they're like I don't
really care I mean I just I want to
raise my family I just want to be left
alone I want to be able to eat I will
maybe a little extra money soul wife and
I can go off for a nice weekend that's
people it's when everybody starts
telling them it's then you know that's
keeping you down that's when there's
trouble do you find it weird in a way
that we're thought of as political
beasts because in a certain way we
really haven't talked about politics
here and I find now I'm probably less
interested in politics now today then
I've ever been in my adult life in a
bizarre way you know you mean like I
said I still love it at some level but
like what we're doing here and what I
think the real conversation happening in
the world right now is is not political
there's a class of people that are
trying to make everything political and
keep you confused and controlled looting
the Russians you see the latest the
Russians believe it or not the Russians
one of their one of their campaigns
happened when I don't remember which was
that the last the last Star Wars movie I
think I did see this day they said that
the last Jedi that is Russian BOTS right
but well that's what Rian Johnson I
guess what it was there is evidence that
they were they were politicizing the
movie that they were they were putting
out oh you're not going to like that
robot because that robot it's all about
social justice we're seeing it the movie
did suck and we you know I'm with you
what but what I'm saying is we have
outside influences that are trying to
make everything about politics read the
book defying Hitler the best best
explanation of what happened in Germany
ever written by a guy
at the time as a warning to the West
cone you don't know what you don't know
where we've been you don't know what's
happening here
warning and so he really gives you a
look at what was happening prior to and
you can see you're like oh my gosh
that's the World Trade Center going down
oh my gosh that's this you can see it
we're repeating it and he says right
right around 1933 nothing is not
political there is not one topic that is
political when did this happen to us
it's incredible I mean just you know I
never watch cable news anymore and I
don't even watch sports channels anymore
because it's all political but when I'm
not doing cardio I'll just flip channels
and everything you go to his political
the view is now always political if
you're watching women's you know
basically women's television in the
morning the the ESPN now is political
all the time I mean every channel you
probably turn on the Food Channel and
there's some political situation
happened let me tell you something that
I've never said how loud only person I
think that even knows it in my own
company
oh it's do my executive producer I
couldn't tell you any of the names of
the people that are running for House
and Senate I'm on talk radio I don't I
don't care I pay somebody to look at
that tell me what's the balance of the
house for the audience
it does not affect me one iota except in
the big picture which movement is moving
I just it it's a waste of our time
think of how many man-hours America has
lost in the last 15 years think of what
we could have done with all of this time
forget about the money is that the best
argument for basically sort of classical
liberalism or libertarianism that if we
could just rein this thing in that not
only could you live however you wanted
to live basically if the government was
just pretend protecting your your life
and your property rights your rights
right that not only would that be good
because you could do what you want but
it would actually it won't save you
money and so but yeah you could heal
yeah you'd still have it you'd have it
still on the the local side which would
be great that right you know I you what
I mean is you'd still have people who
tried to take the local area and they'd
be the big boss of the area so you'd
have those things you know but at least
you'd have a little more control over
the head you could control it or you
could move to the next town yeah you
know what I mean San Francisco can be as
weird as it wants to be they could live
in you know six feet of human poop
that's fine if that's what you want to
do you know there's an app for the human
poop did you know that I'm not kidding
there's actually an app that tells you
where human poop is on the streets in
San Francisco
literally Glenn Beck it's insane it's
insane
I remember saying I remember saying
people there's gonna come a time when
you will not recognize your country what
you thought was solid will be liquid
what you thought was real will be false
you're not going to recognize it we're
not only so far past that point now to
where you're like I don't even know who
anyone is I don't know what is real
what's I don't know up and down anymore
we're so far past that what's incredible
and this is a good thing or could be a
good thing because of technology by 2030
you're not gonna recognize it anything
nothing will be the same nothing will be
the same it will be the difference
between looking at our lives in 2030
looking back and going
tave you remember 2018 when we sat it
will be as different then as if we were
sitting in now and going man can you
imagine what 1920 was like it's going to
be that different you know this reminds
me of a line I interviewed Peter Thiel a
couple weeks ago and he said that crypto
is for libertarians and AI is for
authoritarians and I think that that
sort of gets to the heart of what you're
saying because maybe what's going to
happen here is that as our institutions
our political institutions academic
institutions me
institutions as they become so big they
can't sustain themselves anymore so
maybe we will sort of break off into
smaller communities whatever that means
and we'll sort of about yeah what that's
what the Declaration of Independence in
the Constitution encouraged encouraged
break off do your own thing you should
be a little laboratory be a little
laboratory you'll come up with something
great I'm sure the other states and the
other cities will adopt it if if it
works we're all of it stop stop it's
it's not one experiment why are we
civilian why are we so afraid of that
because I push that idea constantly and
and it's like you know just that the
laboratory should exist so that if you
want low taxes you go here but then if
that screws over the schools then go
somewhere else or whatever it is that
that play but people are really afraid
of that that somehow we're not actually
America if we don't live under the same
exact laws everywhere at which as you
said is the antithesis of the founding
documents I think people just have been
convinced that people are not
trustworthy well people aren't
trustworthy if they never get in trouble
if they never banks are not trustworthy
if they never have to pay for their own
mistakes they're not trustworthy when
you have to pay for your own mistake you
learn people generally become
trustworthy you brought up Peter Thiel
people ask me all the time are you
concerned about deeply yes I'm concerned
about deep platforming big-time and
especially Dave with what's coming with
with deep fakes and all there is trouble
on the horizon Peter every time somebody
says something I always say you know the
guy who can solve this Peter teal
because we need a platform and I mean
left and right a platform whose Charter
is the Bill of Rights that's it if you
agree with the Bill of Rights you're not
trying to shut anybody up you believe in
these things these human principles what
make us human come on what you think on
here we're not gonna kick anybody off
we're not gonna do anything this is a
this a place where speech will
we'll be protected because thoughts are
supposed to be dangerous it's only the
dangerous thoughts that led us to the
moon it's only the dangerous thoughts
that invented television or the internet
it's a dangerous thought that that said
I wonder if I can make fire like the sky
does that's a dangerous thought you're
gonna burn everything down
well they didn't yeah well I can't say
more than if you saw my chat with Erik
Weinstein a couple weeks ago the
billionaire class is talking now so
there there is some happy to hear that
yeah one other thing on that and then I
will let your staff do other I assume
they have other work to do around here
you people do another work around yeah
you got things to do today do do you
think that if we get out of this thing
and it's basically okay out of this sort
of morass that we're in right now and
that it's basically okay that we'll look
back on this and think whoa there was
something really good that came out of
it
because yeah Barack Obama was my biggest
nemesis you don't know you don't know
what it's like to come under attack
until the President of the United States
and I've had two of them now yeah is
coming after you directly and using the
force of his friends and allies to come
after you who was the other one that
went after was at trial it was John yeah
during but yeah at the beginning at the
beginning yeah so I'm calling you after
you basically were like all right no no
no you didn't get anything nothing no no
and I'm fine with that yeah that will
come out on their side though we'll look
back and this is Brock Obama and Donald
Trump have been some of the best things
that's ever happened to me and I don't
mean financially or you know whatever I
mean as a man because they've both taken
me by the lapels and shoved me up
against the wall and said what is it you
really believe we are so blessed do you
know that really even my father's
generation he came at the end of
he was born in 26 so he you know he saw
World War two and stuff but anybody who
really grew up and lived from 1946 until
now we really have been very blessed but
we've also been cursed mm-hmm
no one has had to have everything about
them challenged I'm a better man you're
a better man because every time somebody
throws you up against the wall we will
be a better country we'll be a stronger
more vibrant more free people if we
behave ourselves and learn from what's
throwing us up against the wall
that's how you have didn't interview
back good work
[Music]